all right let's get to your questions
everybody the only big news of the day
give me some uh email question
music feel like it would be elevator
music I feel like I need multiple
instruments for
this make the noise with your
mouth I'm not even I'm not even going to
do it anymore just also for the fact
that you stared me directly in my face
took off your glasses and win make the
sound with your mouth make the noise
with your mouth both are bad just move
on there
there is to be no music for this not
after my own father just asked me to
make that sound with my mouth noise both
of them are bad no one is
funny both are
weird can you just carry on with the
with the with the questions dude I I may
I I use very specific words why you
[__] with my words why why are the
words even coming out of your mouth in
the first
place that's what I